i want to jump to uh this next story
here from the national review
sounds about right xcia chief michael
hayden implies trump should be executed
for taking classified documents
so jack um civil war
yeah again you know you've got people
like michael hayden general michael
hayden head of the cia someone who's
actually had people executed right
overseas
uh in drone strikes going ahead and just
using that same type of language
meanwhile by the way the right is
supposed to we're being told we have to
tone down our rhetoric because of this
guy in cincinnati but you got the
general out there saying this michael
hayden is saying it on from the cia from
the fbi when how many weeks has it been
since gen uh justice kavanaugh and his
family were nearly shot to death by a
crazy left-wing redditor who had in his
backpack uh flex cups and duct tape he
had a nine millimeter glock on him and
this was the same guy who had posted you
saw they pulled his internet searches
right
oh yeah yeah and he was looking for
other
well he was looking for other justices
and then he also googled how to be
stealthy
uh assassin skills and where best place
to stab someone wow
i was i was actually assuming that was
gonna be like mixed in there was gonna
be something like about you know
beautiful women in your area or
something like that uh actually yes so
he posted on reddit
and came out as mtf
and was and was looking for someone to
cuddle with
on
i forget exactly which subreddit it was
but was posting in those in those chats
looking for a cuddle said hey i'm really
into movies and i'm looking for someone
who's also into movies and i just want
to cuddle i don't it's you know it's
like friends but it's kind of my own
thing that i'm working on
yeah everybody needs a good cuddle come
on 100 mtf is male to female that's
right okay all right so here's what uh
michael beschloss tweeted he tweeted
rosenbergs were convicted of giving u.s
nuclear secrets to moscow and were
executed june 1953
and a bunch of these outlets like media
was like they never actually said
anything about trump in the tweet he's
just sharing some fun facts and then if
you look at his series of tweets which
he like says a bunch of stuff that
tweets this and says a bunch of stuff
it's all like trump may have given
secrets out or something like that what
if trump gave an adversary nuclear code
so so before we get too far down the the
rabbit hole in this just
from from a basic overall standpoint
that doesn't apply to the executive that
doesn't apply to the commander-in-chief
so trump we were talking about this
before we came on air but trump when he
was the president joe biden currently
barack obama when he was president for
all presidents right
they have
plenary
declassification authority the same way
that he's plenary pardon power which i
actually tweeted this morning that you
know um you know the people who said
that trump should have pardoned
no don't pardon assange don't pardon
snowden don't pardon old bricks why
because then you might have trouble with
the doj yeah that look how that worked
out right you know so but by the same
token he can declassify whatever he
wants whenever he wants because he is
the authority there's no authority over
him for that imagine donald trump goes
to meet with vladimir putin
and he's trying to negotiate denuclear
demilitarization denuclear
nuclearization which has been u.s russia
policy for 50 years so he goes to putin
says look i'd love to tell you about how
we're going to de-escalate but it's all
classified i can't i can't negotiate
with you like what the president
literally has to negotiate with the
president of other countries about
nuclear strat like all the time weapons
right this has been
going back to reagan gorbachev going
back to carter the assault treaties i
mean this obviously they're going to be
discussing nuclear weapons posture
because that's a jfk and the cuban
missile crisis and then the missiles
that we had in turkey that was like the
secret agreement um to pull those back
it would be honestly if they
retroactively retroactively go back in
time and charge all presidents with
treason for discussing our weapon stock
pilots so you're saying we should
convict jfk yeah back in time dig up his
corpse
if it's available did his head disappear
his brain disappeared after he was
killed there was like a con
theory that his brain went missing went
missing because it was too much evidence
about how he got hit they said it was
one bullet in the back of the head but
they're like actually it was multiple
bullets but we can't find his brains i
don't know how any person will be able
to take chunks of brain and be like this
was more than one bullet yeah pearl
jamrow brains of j it's a song of theirs
all about that anyway he's got the
brains of jfk when we're at the point
where you have an msnbc host nbc staffer
historian
and a former cia director
insinuating trump should face execution
well what's the story here so he said by
the way could you imagine if i like me
and charlie kirk get up at a turning
point event we just start talking about
uh dr fauci and
joe biden any of any of the bidens
anyone by name with with this type of
language right we're done we'd be
completely done we'd be we'd probably be
arrested by the time we got off january
26 2021 marjorie taylor green indicated
support for executing prominent
democrats in 2018 and 2019 before
running for congress there you go just
all this indicated and suggests
potentially that crap like what just
potentially what's the before we get
going to her i mean we could look at her
stuff too but what did the guy say that
said he implied that he may
i saw a quote that said like that may be
cool or whatever he said sounds about
right sounds about right and it's all
out of context and it's like implied
it's not out of context michael
has a thread where he's like what if
donald trump was selling our nuclear
secrets then the news came out from
washington post which was basically fake
news saying they were looking for
nuclear documents and he said i'm
re-upping this tweet then he said
so he tweeted that before the article
yes oh oh he treated before the article
came out wow then after the article came
out he said i'm re-upping my tweet here
to highlight this don't want to be
overly speculative made some other
comments about donald trump and nuclear
documents then posted this
and then posted more about how how
imperative is imperative we must get the
search warrant to understand what they
were looking for basically saying before
the article came out donald trump may
have had nuclear weap codes or secrets
and he may have been selling them oh no
this story's suggesting he did
we executed people who did that before
we better get that search warrant now
and then the cia guy said sounds about
right but like in what context did he
put it on the twitter thread or did he
yeah
yeah
that we but what is he talking seattle
what does he do which by the way that
was actually
by the way
the rose that was how that was the
building the because
back in the 1950s the the ability to
build nuclear weapons was a closely
guarded us secret
and
only we had it obviously it was it was a
huge advantage of of us over the soviet
union and for the soviets even after
they got it later it was a huge
advantage for them over communist china
it's one of the reasons that led to the
sino-soviet split because the soviets
never wanted chairman mao to have
nuclear weapons but then
they get it anyway the u.s exacerbates
this etc etc but the rosenbergs the
whole point was that they were selling
how to build nuclear weapons which is
totally different than just saying you
know hey we've got six thousand but
we'll break it down to five thousand if
we can sign this treaty and right you
know also i mean if trump had nuclear
codes they were defunct they were from a
year ago and that what would giving
ancient nuclear codes to someone do
because they have different codes now
why would he why would he it's just do
you know about trump's red button no the
reason i heard the story the reason i
saw the meme of the button being smashed
no but so okay so when trump was locked
the door when women walked in his office
no no he didn't work for msnbc
um
matt lauer right um
and then so no so trump had a red button
on his desk when he was president and
that button was attached to a
a wooden box
and he would have people into his office
and the oval office and when they were
having the meeting he would just in the
middle of the meeting just randomly go
oh sorry no i know i know everybody's
looking at that at that button nobody
wants you to put that button here i'm
just going to push it away and he'd push
it away from himself on the desk
and then trump pushes the button and
then and then just like slides it away
and then everyone's and then he's like
no don't worry about the button don't
worry it's just it's just there and then
he would go back and you were saying you
know and they'd all be that because he
would know that they'd still all be like
totally fixated on the button and then
and then every once in a while he might
just kind of lean over and then he'd
just kind of like tap it and then
everybody's freaking out in the middle
but you know they're not trying to say
anything because it's the oval office
you have to have the decorum etc and
then eventually what would happen is a
side door would open up and then
somebody would walk in
with a diet coke for him and that's what
is that real dead serious no dead
serious get a diet coke button in the
olaf go pull it up
dead serious i feel like tim is now like
what am i going to get what's my button
going to be tim's like i want a red
button what would you have for red
button tim uh
new beanies
a bottle of water maybe bottled water i
got my water i can get it myself i don't
really need one
coconut water no
i don't know maybe some bacon or that we
should get ian a graphene but actually
made out of graphene okay press a button
yes and then bring up two pieces of
crispy bacon not too crispy but crispy
enough do you like it blackened like a
chard no no no no no i like it
like the fatty parts would be fatty but
the rest should be pretty good i don't
know you can fold it and kind of get it
together yeah i like it disintegrating
but i like it just right before
regarding bacon fat like what's a
healthy amount of daily
fat as much as but like just from what i
strip i pour the whole thing into my
eggs yeah you should and look how much
weight i lost yeah yeah you've i even in
i i think it's been a couple weeks since
i was here but even even from then to
now you've definitely lost weight
interest and i've done it by pouring
bacon grease into my eggs you factor
your fit and your eyes hate fat cat face
i really want you to write a diet like
book now the wondering the wonderful
powers of bait and bacon huge thing of
butter i i put a fourth cup of cream
into my coffee real butter
real oh farm butter better be real body
yes
i can't describe the smell it is like
when you cook with store-bought butter
and then you go buy farm butter it's
insane the smell is so dramatic you
realize you've been lied to your entire
life yeah it's like you it's like waking
up for the first time and you're like
right it's almost like water that farm
butter it's so pure and clean yeah yeah
it's amazing it's like when i'm when i'm
in eastern europe we just when we were
in poland and then or from uh visiting
tony's family it's like that that's what
everything's like over there they don't
real food
getting um having milk in europe was
crazy it tastes so different yeah it's
so rich real it's so rich let's
let's let's deal with the well to deal
with the fat though i mean we can't go
overlook that the fact that fat has been
lied about so many years in this country
fake news by the industry but the fake
news if you want to talk fake news let's
talk about the food pyramid right yeah
you know
so this is
anytime i get a chance to talk about
this it's it's just they're they've been
lying to you they've been lying to you
for 50 years about fat bread and grain
and pasta they wanted you to eat that is
the primary source of diet
frequently absolutely not
i got that all growing up that
propaganda we all did we all did we all
did it was that and that acid rain and
quicksand were like everywhere yeah
apparently i saw a new article said that
rain on earth is no longer safe to drink
because of micro plastic i don't know
what they're called pfct i'm just like
dude get out of cities hey regarding
cities regarding civil war butter is
better outside of the city you have to
leave hold on hold on real quick i'll
throw it in real quick there's there's a
little there's a farm near us and they
have a little farm stand and you walk up
and they give you butter they they did
like themselves they put in the thing
they seal it they hand it to you it's
amazing couple bucks it's like
and it just it will your mind is blown
by how delicious you know joanne's been
making butter did she tell you about it
my mom got a butter churner yeah i kind
of want to get a butter churn yeah uh
you were gonna say something about civil
war well yeah whether or not it's a
civil war i think it's semantic one side
knows how to make the butter one side
doesn't work
guns and butter right guns and butter
i've been thinking lately that it's more
of a fifth generation world war and that
i'm what i'm concerned about is that
they're going to use the united states
as the proxy and it's going to be an
asian versus european war and they're
going to just
let it happen here and they'd be happy
to see us go they'd be happy to see this
country get leveled get taken over get
dis dissipated whatever well china
doesn't want us
destroyed the same way they don't want
taiwan destroyed because we're their
market right we're their consumers you
must consume
uh so if you if they lose the united
states and and yeah they're certainly
building in with with europe and they're
making their inroads all over the place
in europe but you know you lose the
united states you lose your biggest
customer yeah but rebuilding would we be
in desperate straits and we need to buy
that steel from someone if we had to
rebuild too i know what you mean though
i don't think anyone really wants the
the infrastructure blown up or anything
but i think
ultimately england we think of them as
our friends france as our friends but
in the heat of the moment i think
they're all going to look at the united
states and be like you know what
warmonger you're on your own and if we
need to fight china in kansas we're
going to fight china in kansas thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you